ah mais ça la case pour moment
wavecom et palladio les mains déjà un
bon team temps
comment apprendre à machemont l'agent
des eaux avec moi non latins ya moins
[Musique]
d'un mois la main sur elle alors poêler
la réunion de match à la case mon papa
il s'en retrouve en joli village mon
petit cousin petits camarades en train
de couver dans le fond d'un ravin
en train de couver dans faudra vite et
mon petit frère
bien moins
d'amway la main chemin ou
[Musique]
demain ils sont atteints ce moment de
manu salazie mon papa demain messe à la
case mon petit frère de m'amuser à la
case opposants de maïs à la case mon
bonhomme de mam et salades à ce moment
dame de menu salade montgobert magnus à
la case moment demain messe à la casse
des menus saragosse
[Musique]
le ca la case moment